let's go to our next caller from the
three one four area code caller from
three one four please introduce yourself
tell me what's on your mind today
hi gave it this is Vicky I'm from st.
Louis Missouri
oh great what's on your mind well I've
got a couple of things first of all I
saw your podcast on YouTube about in in
the Netherlands when the reporters were
laughing and forcing their the
ambassador to the Netherlands to answer
the questions and they still wouldn't
answer the questions that that whole
climate I wish I'm with you I wish our
reporters would do the same thing yes
and then my question I wanted to ask are
most of the people and I'm not I don't
know if they are not I'm just asking on
most of the people in the Republican
Party who are not standing up to Trump
are they involved in things that they
don't want discovered or do they think
Trump will get away with all this crap
he's involved in and they want to be on
the power side I mean aren't they normal
thinking people who know they see what's
going on no not all of them are I mean
there's there's all of the above Vicki
so there are people who are not standing
up to Trump because they are trumpets
and they are working with Trump so they
benefit from Trump maintaining
unfettered and unobstructed power there
are people who probably don't agree with
what Trump is doing but they see him as
a force in politics and they just don't
want to end up on the wrong side of
Trump and then there are probably some
who literally just are not with it in
any way so I think it's all all of the
above every every single one of those
possibilities and more explain why most
Republicans say they like what Trump is
doing and they support the guy yeah I I
just can't understand that I really
can't I also I want to ask about the
senators who are resigning right um you
know they seem like people who could
stand up to him and yet they're bailing
I I don't understand what
Trump adds that people are so afraid
like who um senator flake okay for one
and I'm blanking on name okay no but
Mike's a good example I mean here let's
think about flake right so flake it's a
combination he at some point he was
going to get out right senator stay
differing amounts of time in the Senate
right he has become a target of Trump
and even though they can stand up to
Trump it wasn't clear flake was
definitely going to win if Trump
bandwagon against him so for a lot of
them it's just a calculated decision
like if they were thinking I've got one
or two more terms left I don't want to
end up yeah leaving because I lose I'd
rather leave on my own terms they just
make the decision to get out I agree all
right they just they don't think they
have enough support to fight him yeah
unfortunately that's that's the reality
for a lot of them Vicki thank you so
much for the call I appreciate it okay
thank you bye bye all right